c'est un peu le joyau des équipes
soignantes ce bassin de balnéothérapie
n'a pas encore pu recevant de patients
crise sanitaire oblige depuis octobre
novembre 2020 les patients ont intégré
le tout nouvel institut mgen sur les
pôles santé mentale qui ont eux intégrer
les locaux depuis plus d'un an
effectivement c'est les patients ont
intégré locaux et c'est quasiment
complet par contre sur les pannes
il ya une montée en charge progressive
en plus il ya une augmentation de
capacité par rapport à l'établissement
précédent il est passé à 186 places
versus 116 4 pôles santé sur 37 hectares
de terrain des bâtiments à haute qualité
environnementale
l'institut a aujourd'hui une capacité de
450 lits le chantier a permis de
rapprocher les différents services au
travers notamment de tous les aspects
sociaux thérapie avec le travail qui est
fait autour de la bibliothèque des
patients qui aussi la bibliothèque des
résidents de l'ehpad avec la prise en
charge autour de l'idée que le patient
est un citoyen le résident est un
citoyen et que
aussi bien l'un que l'autre doivent
trouver leur place dans la vie de
l'institut et dans la reconstruction
face à leur maladie
le site a été inauguré le vendredi 2
juillet dernier en présence de nadia
ministre de la ville
installé dans le parc du château de la
verrière l'institut pourrait passer un
partenariat avec la ville le lien entre
la verrière élèves jeunes doit être
renforcée donc on a répondu
conjointement à un appel à projet de la
rs l' agence régionale de santé pour
avoir des médecins ville hôpital qui se
partageraient entre une activité pour
les verriers roi est une activité pour
la mgen
donc on attend la réponse de l'art est
un centre de santé pourrait aussi voir
le jour pour pallier l'absence de
médecins sur la commune
le chantier de l'institut débuter à
l'été 2016 a représenté un
investissement de 100 millions d'euros